in 1963 if you wanted to do calculations
you had a mechanical calculator like
this wonderful odd nur brunsviga but
it's all mechanical this guy 1962-63 Bob
Dragan worked at Frieden incorporated
maker of mechanical calculators had this
idea let's invent an all-electronic
calculator indeed nothing mechanical in
it it's all electronic and I've been
lucky enough to not just get one of them
but to meet and talk with the late Bob
Reagan who came by and helped me repair
two of them signed by Bob Reagan August
2006 this is a cathode ray tube out of
an oscilloscope for circuit boards it's
all discrete transistors each one of
these is one transistor each of these
probably cost five or ten dollars in
1962 germanium transistors resistors
diodes circuit boards that are not just
double sided but sort of in an odd way
four sided it folds in on itself plugs
in and there are four different but even
that's not what I find amazing in a
calculator you have to keep track you
don't need a memory you need to keep
track of the numbers where's the memory
this used a piece of piano wire from
memory you would tweak one end of the
piano wire vibrate go around around
around in a spiral and at the far end
there'd be a little microphone to hear
it each pulse was a ding ding it was
called recirculating audio acoustic
memory it's all in here the number 5
binary zero one zero one had to have
ding no ding ding so a ding was a bit it
remembers in time it takes about Oh a
hundredth of a second for these little
bits to go around this long spiral come
on over Freddie check this out
now let's look over here
first you can see there's a spiral out
here every time there's a bit like the
first the first bit in the number five
over here is a little speaker that goes
point little magnetic coil it so it goes
point and launches a pulse
a little blink goes around here on the
spiral of piano wire steel wire it
spirals in then spirals out and a couple
of milliseconds later it gets to the far
end where there's a tiny microphone and
amplify microphone over here which goes
out into an amplifier and then into the
circuit boards so the memory of this
calculator is all acoustic ever there
every time you type a number into it the
bitstream of the number is represented
continuously as vibrations in this wire
the alternative of course is what we do
today
you'd have solid-state memory well
solid-state memory well there's five
let's say there's six entries in the
stack each one has say ten digits it's
more than that's 13 digits well let's
say ten times six is sixty digits times
four bits per digit it's on the order of
250 maybe if I I would need somewhere
between 200 and 500 transistors and each
transistor is costing me a dollar that's
big bucks and on top of that it takes up
space so rather than using transistors
as we would today for memory put all the
information in acoustic memory okay I'm
working on this my problem is in August
of 2006 I got it work
it was working in November of 2013 today
I'm sorry guys it's sort of I'm sorry
it's sort of not working very well and
I'm going in with an oscilloscope
it's the oscilloscope is there okay
so unfortunately you can see it's
dancing around if we type a number in
BAM uh I can see that two of the
scanning boards are working I can also
see that I've got some troubles in the
arithmetic board and the logic nope I've
got work to do the happy thing is
alongside this that Bob Reagan helped me
fix I've got a second one which happily
as of last night what's working not sure
it's working now but let me give it a
try if I'm lucky
Oh we'll do all our calculations with
seven decimal places there is a stack of
four four numbers and I enter on the
lowest stack which should be brightest
I'll enter 20 to enter now I have 22 oh
I'm going to divide by seven seven
divided 3.14 an approximation for pi we
just showed that it divided let's do a
square root square root of 2/2 square
root watch how long it takes OOP it
takes a second to do a square root let's
actually go all the way out do it to
twelve decimal places to square root it
takes the better part of a second to
find the square root of two but it does
it and in 1963 people were astonished
hey when I first used this in college in
1971-72 I was astonished
bring the square root of two dozen
decimal places in a second Wow I don't
have to look it up I don't have to do an
expansion absolutely sweet so this
machine that I'm working on I compare
voltages to this working machine so I'm
in there and you can see a hope it's
visible Brady that so now let's do the
square root of 2 1 point 1 4 let's crank
the decimal place back here clear entry
22 enter 7 divided and there it's an
approximation for pi a little bit of
lousy you know few digits of
approximation and so to repair this guy
I'll be comparing voltages from this guy
here into here and check this out of
course it's a continuing problem
November 2013 repaired ok so this guy's
working why do I work on this it's
partly out of respect for those who came
before me brilliant engineers it's
partly out of a sense of appreciation
for their work for for their their use
of the available technology that today
people will laugh at it discrete
transistors I'm not sure you can buy a
discrete germanium transistor anymore
certainly not one they bet made by Texas
Instruments its admiration for those who
came before me and of course it's also a
wonderfully entertaining jigsaw puzzle
debugging software hey I don't need much
more than a computer and a brain
debugging hardware it means
understanding not just what's supposed
to happen understanding not just what is
happening but also understanding what
was in the mind of the people who
created this the reason for for working
on this isn't oh look I've got a museum
piece no that doesn't mean anything the
reason is it teaches me gives me a sense
of
of joy that I I'm bringing to life what
people who came before me gave birth to
every time I want it let's try something
slightly more complex let's set this to
fourteen million six hundred five three
one so this is fourteen million six
hundred thirty seven thousand five
hundred thirty one